to which degree did
would you say marx
marx's ideas
led to the creation of the
uh
national socialism party of german
workers hence the nazi party the fascist
party in the 30s and the 40s
at the head of whom was
uh hitler which i just recently learned
he was
employee number seven of the party or
whatever the seventh person to have
joined the party and have created one of
the most uh consequential and powerful
political parties in the history of the
20th century
what degree did mark's ideas
marxism ideas have to play it is the
national
socialist
party of german workers right
workers naturalistic such the national
society
german worker party worker party
national socialist german worker party
so well here's the history the uh did he
care about the workers or did he just
use the workers as a populist message
the only thing that marxism
did for mr hitler was provide him
with his stepping stone to power but it
had nothing no other he didn't know
anything about it didn't care anything
about it nor did the people around him
here's the story of what happened there
uh which i know largely through my own
family and plus my own history the work
that i did
um
the most successful socialist party in
europe was the german party it started
around 1870 marxist was still alive some
of his own family were leaders fernando
lassal and other his daughters
by the end of the century it was the
second most important party in germany
nobody understood it it was overwhelm it
was almost as big a shock
to the europeans as was the russian
revolution in 1917. here was a political
party that was now in every german city
in every german town
powerful
and enjoying its rise up uh
that's my family is involved in this so
i mean i really do know the story
it meant that starting
around 19678
if you wanted to have any kind
of presence
in the german working class
you had to use the word socialist you
had to otherwise
they wouldn't pay attention
the other parties call themselves
catholic
germany is divided the upper two the
northern two thirds is protestant the
southern third is catholic munich and
bavaria it's catholic and every other
part of germany basically is a
protestant um you could be in the
catholic party that was the south
or you could be in various conservative
prussian and other but if you wanted to
have a presence in the working class
which was growing every in germany a
very powerful capitalist country
expanding like crazy at this time you
know germany was the major competitor to
britain for the empire the united states
was was coming up too but it was germany
and us taking over from britain's empire
so the german working class was it
so
anybody who wanted to approach
the working class in whatever way
had to come to terms and be friendly to
socialism
other parties did this too just like
hitler they put the word socialist in
their party but they wanted to make it
clear that they weren't
uh
anything to do with the soviet union or
anything to do with marxism so they put
the word national
nazi is the first four letters of
national nazional in german and azis how
you spell
national in the german national
socialism but definitely not communists
that's right they killed coming they
they fought communists in the street
they they had pitched battles
they literally threatened each other's
existence and their life and the first
people that he arrested and put in jail
were not jews and gypsies and all the
other people he eventually killed it was
communists they were the the number one
socialist right behind him why because
up until he takes power january of 1933
that's when hitler takes power the last
elections two of them in 1932
the socialists and communists the vote
together 50 of the vote in germany so
he appealed to the the german
uh manufacturers the german capitalist
and he said
the communists and socialists are going
to win
you won't and you you're just the
capitalist you have too few people
you need a mass base and i'm the only
one that can do that
and there's just the populist message
that he used that's right but it was
explicitly done as a deal the the the
ruling group said to hindenburg the old
prussian man who was in charge of the
german government at the time you have
to invite hitler to form a new
government otherwise he would never have
done he had called hitler nasty names
before the prussian aristocracy looked
down on hitler as an awes a little funny
man with a mustache who was austria
wasn't even german you know
for them that mattered so
he he comes in as the enemy
the smasher of socialism and communism
which he immediately does
only people who don't know or care about
the history
pick up on the word
you know it's like
there are people here in the united
states who like to say
we are not a democracy we are republic
which is like saying i'm not a banana
i'm a fruit
you have to explain to these people
so you have to explain to people yes
we're a republic
but we have a commitment to democracy as
a way to govern the republic because to
say you're a republic doesn't imply what
kind of government you have to go
through that with people so they kind of
get it and certain words
have power beyond their actual meaning
that's used in communication whether
it's negative
like racist or positive like freedom of
speech or democrat or death
yeah and then you use that to mean
something who knows or negative uh what
stop donnie stop being a socialist yeah
or some whatever what whatever that
means that's not even used as in any
kind of philosophical economic sense
you